and they'll be by the way it's  phenomenal in this and I got a peek at  the production's life that was Tamron  hall on Tuesdays today's show it was  also her last episode NBC announced  Wednesday that the 46 year old is  leaving NBC News and MSNBC in the  official statement the network Grey's  Damron adding we are disappointed that  she has chosen to leave but we wish her  all the best  Tamron said the last 10 years have been  beyond anything I could have imagined  and I'm grateful I'm also very excited  about the next chapter  Camryn's departure comes after news  broke that megyn kelly was taking over  the third hour of The Today Show  replacing Tamron and al Roker's today's  take segment Roker will continue to  co-host the third hour until a new  morning lineup begins this fall  chairman joined MSNBC and NBC in 2007  and became part of the Today team in  2014 there is a whole thing about Tim  your hair what you're wearing Thank You  Robert I'm wearing natural hair in my  life